in the entire Quran there's only one
woman who's mentioned by name Mary the
mother of Jesus not the mother of
Abraham or Moses or Muhammad just the
mother of Jesus the Quran says a lot
about Mary it talks about her parents
her upbringing her miraculous pregnancy
and the birth of her son Jesus there's
even a chapter of the Quran named after
her suret
miam this raises an important
question why is Mary so special and
unique in the
Quran to find the answer we'll go
through everything the Quran says about
Mary taking you from beginner level to
expert level on this topic in a single
video we won't go through every verse
that mentions Mary because there are a
number of verses that refer to Jesus as
Jesus Son of Mary but don't say anything
else about Mary we won't read those
because they're not telling us anything
about Mary except that she's the mother
of Jesus but we'll go through every
verse in the Quran that adds anything
else we'll read these in order according
to the chapters the passages are found
in and we'll start with a long passage
in Surah 3 Surah 3: 33-
51 truly God chose Adam Noah the house
of Abraham and the house of Imran above
the worlds as progyny one from another
and God is hearing knowing God chose two
individuals Adam and Noah and two
families Abraham and Imran Imran is the
Islamic version of amram if you're
familiar with Old Testament genealogies
amram is the father of Aaron Moses and
Miriam so you might think that the house
of Imran here or the house of amram
refers to Aaron Moses Miriam and their
descendants but not so fast let's keep
reading remember when the wife of Imran
said my Lord truly I dedicate to thee
what is in my belly in consecration so
accept it from me truly Thou Art the
hearing the knowing and when she bore
her she said my Lord I have borne a
female and God knows best what she bore
and the male is not like the female and
I have named her Mary and I seek refuge
for her in thee and for her progeny from
Satan the
outcast so the wife of Imran the wife of
amram gives birth to a daughter and
names her Mary but this is Mary the
mother of Jesus not Miriam the sister of
Aaron and Moses the father of Aaron
Moses and Miriam you'll recall was amram
or in Islam Imran
isn't that interesting in Arabic the
name for both Miriam the sister of Aaron
and Moses and Mary the mother of Jesus
is Miriam but we'll return to that point
shortly a lot of the material in this
section of the Quran comes from a late 2
Century apocryphal work called the Proto
evangelium of James here's a passage and
behold an angel of the Lord stood by
saying Anna Anna Anna is the mother of
Mary Anna Anna the Lord has heard your
prayer and you shall conceive and shall
bring forth and your seed shall be
spoken of in all the world and Anna said
as the Lord my God Lives if I beget
either male or female I will bring it as
a gift to the Lord my God and it shall
minister to him in holy things all the
days of its life and the Quran continues
so her Lord accepted her Mary with a
beautiful acceptance and made her to
grow in a beautiful way and placed her
under the care of Zachariah whenever
Zachariah entered upon her in the
sanctuary he found provision with her he
found food with her he said Mary whence
comes this unto thee she said it is from
God truly God provides for whomsoever he
will without Reckoning so a man named
Zachariah takes care of Mary but when he
would go to her in the Sanctuary he
would find that she already had food
provided to her by God as we read in the
Proto evangelium of James and Mary was
in the temple of the Lord as if she were
a dove that dwelt there and she received
food from the hand of an Angel and who
was the priest
Zacharias back to the Quran then and
there Zachariah called upon his Lord he
said my Lord grant me from thy presence
a good progeny truly thou hearest all
calls then the Angels called to him
while he was praying in the sanctuary
God gives the Glad Tidings of John
confirming a word from God Noble and
chaste a prophet from among the
righteous he said my Lord how shall I
have a boy when age has overtaken me and
my wife is Barren he said thus does God
do whatsoever he will
he said my Lord appoint For Me A Sign he
said your sign is that you shall not
speak to the people for 3 Days save
through signs and remember your lord
much and glorify him at even tide and at
dawn some of this should be familiar
from the Gospel of Luke but this part is
about John the Baptist so we'll save it
for a discussion about John the Baptist
in the Quran and remember when the
Angels said oh Mary truly God has chosen
thee and purified thee and has chosen
thee above the women of the worlds oh
Mary be devoutly obedient to thy Lord
prostrate and bow with those who bow
this is from the tidings of the Unseen
which we reveal unto thee and thou was
not with them when they cast their lots
to choose who among them would care for
Mary and thou was not with them when
they were
disputing when they cast their lots to
choose who among them would care for
Mary what's that about who was going to
take care of Mary the Quran doesn't
explain but the Proto evangelium of
James does and Joseph throwing away his
axe went out to meet them and when they
had assembled they went away to the high
priest taking with them their rods and
he taking the rods of all of them
entered into the the temple and prayed
and having ended his prayer he took the
rods and came out and gave them to them
but there was no sign in them and Joseph
took his Rod last and behold a Dove came
out of the rod and flew upon Joseph's
head and the priest said to Joseph you
have been chosen by lot to take into
your keeping the virgin of the Lord but
Joseph refused saying I have children
and and I am an old man and she is a
young girl I am afraid lest I become a
laughing stock to the sons of
Israel so they were casting lots to see
who would take care of Mary since she
was getting older in the Proto
evangelium of James Mary is a Perpetual
virgin Joseph is chosen by lot to marry
her because he's an old man and wouldn't
be interested in consummating the
marriage but even then Joseph is worried
that he'll be a laughing stock in Israel
for marrying a young
girl imagine that imagine a culture
where an old man marrying a young girl
would make him a total laughing stock
among his
people back to the Quran when the Angels
said oh Mary truly God gives thee Glad
Tidings of a word from him whose name is
the Messiah Jesus Son of Mary
High honored in this world and the
Hereafter and one of those brought nigh
he will speak to people in the cradle
and in maturity and will be among the
righteous Jesus is a word from God
plenty of interesting stuff here
especially Jesus speaking to people
while he's still a baby but we'll save
that for a discussion about Jesus in the
Quran she said my Lord how shall I have
a child while no human being has touched
touched me he said thus does God create
whatsoever he will when he decrees a
thing he only says to it be and it is
this is hilarious when you realize that
Mary raises the same objection that
Allah raises in Surah 6 but she gets a
completely different response in Surah 6
verse 101 Allah responds to the claim
that he has a son he says the unique or
originator of the heavens and the Earth
how should he have a child when he has
no consort and he created all things and
he is no of all things so the response
here is how can Allah have a son when he
has no consort no wife or partner what's
the Assumption here the assumption is
that having a child requires both a
mother and a father since Allah has no
wife it's impossible for him to have a
son
but Mary raises the same objection how
can I have a son when no man has touched
me and the response here is what do you
mean Allah can do whatever he wants so
in one passage of the Quran having a
child without two parents is impossible
even for Allah in another passage of the
same Quran having a child without two
parents is easy for Allah and all of
this is massively confusing for
Christians because when we talk about
Jesus being the Son of God we're not
talking about biological reproduction as
the Quran always seems to
assume the rest of this passage is about
Jesus but some of this is being said to
Mary so we'll finish reading and he will
teach him the book wisdom the Torah and
the gospel and he will be a messenger to
the children of Israel truly I have
brought you a sign from your lord I will
create for you out of clay the shape of
a bird then I will breathe into it and
it will be a bird by God's leave and I
will heal the Blind and the leper and
give life to the dead by God's leave and
I will inform you about what you eat and
what you store up in your houses truly
in that is a sign for you if you are
believers and I come confirming that
which was before me the Torah and to
make lawful unto you part of that which
was forbidden unto you and I have come
to you with a sign from your lord so
reverence God and obey me truly God is
my Lord and your lord so worship him
this is a straight path this wraps up
one of the two long passages about Mary
in the Quran let's go through some short
passages in suror there's a section
criticizing Jews for various offenses
verse 156 mentions Mary we'll start a
verse earlier for context then for their
breaking of their Covenant and their
disbelieving in the signs of God and
their slaying of the prophets without
right and their saying our hearts are
uncircumcised nay rather God has set a
seal upon them for their disbelief so
they believe not save a few and for
their disbelief and their uttering
against Mary a tremendous
calumny as the study Quran notes the
tremendous calumny the false and
slanderous accusation against Mary
refers to the implied accusation of
indecency against her when she as an
unmarried woman in the Islamic tradition
brought forth her son Jesus so there
were Jews who were insulting Mary
claiming that she'd had Jesus outside of
wedlock next up Surah 4 verse
171 oh people of the book do not
exaggerate in your religion nor utter
anything concerning God save the truth
verily the Messiah Jesus Son of Mary was
only a messenger of God and his word
which he committed to Mary and a spirit
from him so believe in God and His
Messengers and say not three refrain it
is better for you God is only one God
glory be to him that he should have a
child unto him belongs whatsoever is in
the heavens and whatsoever is on the
earth and God suffices as a
guardian fascinating verse especially
since the Quran is denying the deity of
Christ while claiming that Jesus is the
word of God and a spirit from God the
word of God is something that God speaks
out and a spirit from God is something
he breathes out when Allah creates he
just says be and it comes into existence
but Jesus is different Jesus somehow
originates from within Allah the only
part about Mary here is that Jesus is
the word of Allah
which Allah committed to
Mary or is that the only part about Mary
what is this say not
three it's a rejection of the Trinity
which usually wouldn't have anything to
do with Mary but as we're about to see
Allah thinks that Mary is part of the
Trinity Surah 5:1
17 they indeed have disbelieved who say
God is the Messiah son of Mary say who
would have any power over God if he
desired to destroy the Messiah son of
Mary and his mother and those on Earth
altogether unto God belongs sovereignty
over the heavens and the Earth and
whatsoever is between them he creates
whatsoever he will and God is powerful
over all
things this is a response to Christian
belief in the deity of Christ if you
believe Jesus is god you're an
unbeliever Allah points out that he has
the power to destroy Jesus and Mary and
everyone on the planet Surah 5 verse 75
the Messiah son of Mary was not but a
messenger Messengers have passed away
before him and his mother was truthful
both of them ate food behold how we make
the signs clear unto them yet behold how
they are perverted
here we learn that Mary was truthful and
that she ate food Allah doesn't
understand the doctrine of the
Incarnation so he thinks pointing out
that Jesus ate food is a reputation of
the deity of Christ and again Allah
thinks that Mary is part of the Trinity
so he applies the same objection to her
Surah 5 verse 110 then God will say oh
Jesus Son of Mary remember my blessing
upon thee and upon thy mother when I
strengthened Thee with the holy spirit
that thou mightest speak to people in
the cradle and in maturity and when I
taught Thee the book wisdom the Torah
and the gospel and how thou wouldst
create out of clay the shape of a bird
by my leave and thou wouldst breathe
into it and it would become a bird by my
leave and thou wouldst healed the Blind
and the leper by my leave and thou
wouldst bring forth the dead by my leave
and how I restrained the children of
Israel from thee when thou did bring
them clear proofs and those who
disbelieved among them said this is not
but manifest
sorcery the only part here relevant to
our topic is that Allah strengthened
Jesus with the Holy Spirit and this was
a blessing to both Jesus and
Mary Surah 5 verse
116 and when God said oh Jesus son of
Mary Did thou say unto mankind take me
and my mother as Gods apart from God he
Jesus said glory be to thee it is not
for me to utter that to which I have no
right had I said it thou wouldst surely
have known it thou knowest what is in
myself and I know not what is in thyself
truly it is thou who knowest best the
things
unseen earlier we we read say not three
which is Allah's attempt to respond to
the doctrine of the Trinity here in
Surah 5 verse 116 we find out who's in
the Trinity according to Allah it's God
Jesus and Mary and they're all separate
Gods Allah asks Jesus where people came
up with the idea that Jesus and Mary are
two additional Gods Jesus responds by
saying in effect they didn't get that
from from me true we didn't get that
from anyone because that's never been
the doctrine of the
Trinity now we have the other long
passage Surah 19:
16-36 and remember Mary in the book when
she withdrew from her family to an
Eastern place and she veiled herself
from them then we sent unto her our
spirit and it assumed for her the
likeness of a perfect man so the spirit
of Allah appears to Mary in the form of
a perfect man she said I seek Refuge
from thee in the compassionate if you
are reverent she apparently thought he
was going to assault her he said I am
but a messenger of thy Lord to bestow
upon thee a pure boy she said how shall
I have a boy when no man has touched me
nor have I been
unchaste said thus shall It Be Thy Lord
says it is easy for me and it is thus
that we might make him a sign unto
Mankind and a mercy from us and it is a
matter
decreed this is the same story that we
read in Surah 3 although several details
are different in Sora 3 it was the
Angels who were speaking to Mary here
it's the spirit of Allah in human form
the discussion is a little different as
well but it's the same general Point how
can Mary have have a son when no man has
touched her Allah says it's easy for me
although again this is the same Allah
who says he can't possibly have a son
without a wife so she conceived him and
withdrew with him to a place far off and
the pangs of childbirth drove her to the
trunk of a date palm she said would that
I had died before this and were a thing
forgotten utterly forgotten so he baby
Jesus called out to her from below her
grieve not thy Lord has placed a rivulet
a small stream beneath thee and Shake
toward thyself the trunk of the date
palm fresh ripe dates shall fall upon
thee so eat and drink and cool thine eye
and if thou seest any human being say
verily I have vowed a fast unto the
compassionate so I shall not speak this
day to any man so Mary gives birth to
Jesus in a far off place under a date
palm and the newborn Jesus announces
that God made a stream beneath her and
that she can eat some dates this story
is taken from the apocryphal Gospel of
pseudo Matthew written in the early 7th
Century here's the passage and it came
to pass on the third day of their
Journey while they were walking that the
Blessed Mary was fatigued by the
excessive heat of the Sun in the desert
and seeing a palm tree she said to
Joseph let let me rest a little under
the shade of this tree Joseph therefore
made haste and led her to the palm and
made her come down from her beast and as
the Blessed Mary was sitting there she
looked up to the foliage of the palm and
saw it full of fruit and said to Joseph
I wish it were possible to get some of
the fruit of this palm and Joseph said
to her I wonder that you say this when
you see how high the palm tree is and
that you think of eating its fruit I am
thinking more of the want of water
because the Skins are now empty and we
have none wherewith to refresh ourselves
and our cattle then the Child Jesus with
a joyful countenance reposing in the
bosom of his mother said to the Palm oh
Tree Bend your branches and refresh my
mother with your fruit and immediately
at these words the Palm bent its top
down to the very feet of the Blessed
Mary and they gathered from it fruit
with which they were all refreshed and
after they had gathered all its fruit it
remained bent down waiting the order to
rise from him who had commanded it to
stoop then Jesus said to it raise
yourself o palm tree and be strong and
be the companion of my trees which are
in the paradise of my father and open
from your roots a vein of water which
has been hid in the earth and let the
waters flow so that we may be satisfied
from you and it Rose up immediately and
at its root there began to come forth a
spring of water exceedingly clear and
cool and sparkling and when they saw the
spring of water they rejoiced with great
joy and were satisfied themselves and
all their cattle and their beasts
wherefore they gave thanks to God there
are two important differences between
this version of the story and the
quran's version one in the gospel of
pseudo Matthew this takes place place
after Herod decides to kill all the
babies and Mary and Joseph flee to Egypt
they come to the palm tree on their way
to Egypt but in the Quran this happens
around the time Jesus is born two the
Quran removes Joseph from these stories
no mention of Joseph in these passages
about
Mary why does the Quran remove Joseph
when Joseph is part of the stories that
the Quran is
copying I suspect it has something to do
with Muhammad's father dying before he
was born but we'll cover that when we
discuss the psychology of
Muhammad then she came with him unto her
people carrying him they said oh Mary
thou Hast brought an amazing thing oh
sister of Aaron thy father was not an
evil man nor was thy mother
unchaste did you catch that oh sister of
Aaron the Quran talks about the family
of Imran which is the Islamic version of
amram amram was the father of Aron Moses
and Miriam so Miriam was the sister of
Aaron and the daughter of Imran in the
Quran Mary the mother of Jesus is the
sister of Aaron and the daughter of
Imran since Miriam and Mary are the same
name in Hebrew and in Arabic most most
non-muslims who see this are convinced
that the author of the Quran thought
that Mary the mother of Jesus and Miriam
the sister of Aaron were the same person
in other words Muhammad heard Jews
talking about a woman named Mariam and
he heard Christians talking about a
woman named miam and he thought they
were talking about the same
person this is supported by the fact
that verse 53 of the very same chapter
refers to
as the brother of Moses so non-muslims
generally think this is simply a blunder
like the author of the Quran thinking
that Christians believe in a trinity
composed of God Jesus and Mary but
Muslims don't want to believe that this
is a mistake so here's the commentary in
the study Quran that Mary is addressed
as sister of Aaron is not according to
commentators meant to indicate that she
was the biological sister of the Prophet
Aaron brother of Moses
this would be chronologically impossible
although Mary's father's name is Imran
as is that of the prophets Moses and
Aaron According to Islamic tradition
some commentators explain that the name
Aon signified righteousness among the
Jews of this time and so the title
sister of Aaron was meant to indicate
that Mary was like Aaron in
righteousness another explanation is
that the name Aaron was common among the
Israelites and that Mary had a half
brother named Aaron the most widely held
view among the commentators is that Mary
was a descendant of the Prophet Aaron
and the title sister of Aaron is meant
as a reference to her Noble
lineage long story short they have no
idea why Mary the mother of Jesus is
called the sister of Aaron and the
daughter of Imran so they made up a
bunch of explanations
then she pointed to him they said how
shall we speak to one who is yet a child
in the Cradle he little baby Jesus said
truly I am a servant of God he has given
me the book and made me a prophet he has
made me blessed wheresoever I may be and
has enjoined upon me prayer and
almsgiving so long as I live and has
made me dutiful toward my mother and he
has not made me domineering wretched
peace be upon on me classic catchphrase
the day I was born the day I die and the
day I am raised alive that is Jesus Son
of Mary a statement of the truth which
they doubt it is not for God to take a
child glory be to him when he decrees a
thing he only says to it be and it is
truly God is my Lord and your lord so
worship him this is a straight path this
material is about Jesus but it's
supposedly Jesus saying this to people
who were accusing Mary and that wraps up
the second long passage about Mary we're
down to three short passages Surah 21:
91 and as for she who preserved her
Chastity we breathed into her of our
spirit and made her and her son a sign
for the
worlds Allah says that he breathed his
Spirit into Mary who preserved deserved
her Chastity Palmer gives the literal
translation and she who guarded her
private parts and we breathed into her
of our spirit and we made her and her
son a sign unto the worlds Allah made
Mary and Jesus a sign unto the worlds
Surah 23: 50 and we made the son of Mary
and his mother a sign and we gave them
refuge in a high place of Stillness and
and a flowing spring Mary and Jesus are
again said to be a sign Allah gave them
refuge in a place of Stillness with a
flowing spring this seems to refer to
the same story about the palm tree and
the water we read in Surah 19 taken from
the gospel of pseudo
Matthew finally Surah
66:2 Surah 66 is about a dispute
Muhammad was having with his wives he
got caught having sex with his slave
girl IR ically named Mary in the bed of
his wife haa his wives complained about
him using their beds to have sex with
his slave girl he told them they were
bad wives and in verses 11 and 12 he
gives them the example of two good wives
we'll start with verse 11 and God sets
forth as an example for those who
believe the wife of pharaoh when she
said my Lord build for me a house near
unto thee in the garden deliver me from
pharaoh and his deeds and Deliver Me
from the wrongdoing people and Mary the
daughter of Imran who preserved her
Chastity then we breathed therein of our
spirit and she confirmed the words of
her Lord and his books and she was among
the devoutly
obedient Mary is once again called the
daughter of Imran Imran was the father
of Aaron Moses and Miriam the the
records we have of Mary's father are too
late to be treated as generally reliable
but if they preserved a reliable
tradition about her parents' names her
parents' names were Joakim and
Anna Mary preserved her chasti then
Allah breathed therein of his Spirit
breathed into what her
Chastity let's go once more to the
literal
translation and Mary daughter of Imran
who guarded her private parts and we
breathed therein of our spirit and she
verified the words of her Lord and his
books and was of The Devout Allah
breathed his Spirit into Mary's private
parts and she verified the words of her
Lord and his books and she was of The
Devout and that is everything the Quran
says about Mary the mother of Jesus why
is there so much emphasis on Mary in a
book that never so much as mentions any
other woman by name there are two
apparent reasons first Muhammad thought
that Christians believe in a trinity
made up of God Jesus and Mary so he
wanted to tell the story of Mary to show
that she's not a God and not part of any
Trinity of course this is simply a
mistake on Muhammad's part and we can
understand why Muhammad made that
mistake think about it Muhammad heard
Christians talking about the Trinity he
also heard Christians talking about the
father and the
son and he heard Christians talking
about Mary the mother of Jesus what did
he conclude he concluded that the
Trinity is a little family father mother
and
son unfortunately for Muhammad that not
the doctrine of the Trinity at
all second Muhammad was obsessed with
taking other people's religious figures
and turning them into Muslims today we
hear about forced conversions and we
read about forced conversions in Islam's
most trusted sources but Muhammad wasn't
satisfied with simply compelling the
people of his time to convert to Islam
he forcibly converted people's major
religious figures by re writing their
stories and making them Muslims that's
why the Quran has so much to say about
Mary so now you're an expert on what the
Quran says about Mary the mother of
Jesus I suggest you watch this video
again and take notes because as you may
have noticed there's a lot of
information here that can be extremely
powerful in discussions with your Muslim
friends
[Music]